dominique winter ando ein wertvoller
schatz ja dann ich bin großvater ich bin
sehr kostbare erinnerungen und bezahlbar
für mich er bildet die usa warteten auf
ihre tat wo sie seit über 20 jahren im
exil hat auch langsam verliert sich
geduld
[Musik]
vielen dank
und willi xylander wo sich schon mal auf
der iss die raum vorbereitet
[Musik]
voll und ganz damit in die ärger
verursachen oder nie verpassen
[Musik]
das ist zurück zu den wurzeln dreist wie
nie fremd heimat
rochester in der usa susan wort zweimal
mit ihrer freundin monika auf ihren
vater zu sein ist vor 40 jahren statt
oft weiter wo sich ihre eltern trennten
die mutter mit ihrer tweets zu ihrem
vater vor 21 jahren besucht und sich die
zwei endlich wieder gesehen
abgemacht hinzu steinbrück vor
halbstunden mit ihrem transporter blüte
[Musik]
über sie sagt ja
bogdanov rolling stones und the world
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
um vermisste ja schön mit ihm
was die diskrepanz zwischen wie das
jetzt weist und zwei wochen lud am reden
vorher die schüler und so wird susan auf
der bank wieder zu der marine knightley
wo ihre tat so fest vermisst
[Musik]
für andere ist es der letzte tag auf 30
fremdheit armenien 23 jahre lang ist sie
aber auch die reihe ist seiner freundin
chada die zwei sind vom werk aus graz
vom anders im vater wo vor vier jahren
gestorben ist
amondo ziegler und senioren chrome os
mit die db stieg ein stopp der staat es
wichtig monument armenische auf erbeten
unter dem namen tätowiert auf armenisch
ausgesprochen wird aber madjidi die ada
und jetzt setzt sie zum spaß
diese kontrollieren ob das wirklich so
stimmt
[Musik]
056 manager schuld bin habe ich das
alles verlernt
ich habe mich nur an der buchstabe a wie
lange dran ich mich sehr gut erinnern
muss andronic der schweiz angeboten und
ein siebenjähriger bub mit ihrer familie
geflüchtet ist ein erfolgreicher boxer
[Musik]
amandus in die mutter und die zwei
brüder wohnen in der schweiz kontakt
mehr da ist die wichtigste person ist im
leben
die beiden sind jahres bord
[Musik]
okay okay
[Gelächter]
wieder greift zur heimat dort vom anders
empfunden
am anderen trennt sich das paar nach der
flucht die schweiz trennt der vater ist
wieder zurück auf armenien verhältnis
zwischen vater und sohn ist schwierig
sie die beiden einzigen auge verloren
vor verwandte weiß der andere das ich
warte im alter 1 am tisch und um viel
zeit bis in ihre mutter in zug verbracht
hat dem 23 20 jahren seit er ist jetzt
realität ist
das ist der quasi dorfplatz das ist
zentrum was mir gerade und den arbeiten
der android der stadt jerewan
aufgewachsen ist aber fast jedes
wochenende sehen oder großmutter vom
land in zurndorf erinnere man sich gut
ob familie monatssalär erde sind sicher
zu hause schön
da wird jetzt niemand mehr wenn meine
großmutter vor zehn jahren verstorbene
ich und jetzt lockt immer mehr auf das
eis
es ist zweiter der heim-wm vor vier
jahren gestorben ist
in einer letzten jahre gepflanzt die
absolute absolut bäume es noch bevor ich
dann zeigt sie und mit ihnen kann mich
erinnern
und da sind alle meine großmutter
rechtzeitig dürften bei anlagen diesen
winter denn wenn man die zumeist hätte
ja
was ich brauchte für die bluse ja
und das spiel vater
er ist sehr stolz auf mehr entziehen
der große motor ihres fonds ist voll mit
der in riga mit auf die flucht ein
anderes in die familien
darum ist der koffer im schrank ein
richtiger schatz
ja da nicht bilder gefunden von
großvater von meine mutter
ich begebe mich sagt und nochmals sie
natürlich alle würdig galaxy schaut man
auch so ohne vater aufwachsen zu so
einem leben
ich bin vater der jungs
da groß 40
vielleicht kann ich ein großes team
sucht warum man ist wenn ich die bilder
nicht da ich sie gern mit sind sehr
kostbare erinnerung und bezahlbar für
mich
[Musik]
susan ihre tat donald noch eine 20
jährige die zwei empfohlen
[Musik]
denkt
webmoritz flog die vergangenheit
zynisch und trixi wo sich der trend und
mutter mit ihren zug schweiz
darum hätten home erinnerung chester
donald tiere zu zeigen wo sie als junge
familien in ägypten
[Musik]
hatte
2000 medien eher gewohnt geht's nimmer
blitzstarter zahnarztpraxis und wo fühlt
sie sich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der donald wird mit der vergangenheit
konfrontiert gemeinsame tochter verlor
er muss nadal
[Applaus]
märz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der android os letztes ziel auf der
ice-linie vor dem vater wo vor vier
jahren gestorben ist
zudem zieht ein vater und sohn joe lang
konnte sich selbst einmal wo der
handelsgewinn vater besucht
zuletzt 2006 gesehen eigentlich mit
meinem vater nicht so guten verhältnis
vergangenheit verklären schlager wurde
und und und aber nicht so trotzdem vater
und durch das respekt zollen
[Musik]
auf der reise der andere vor ort dass
sie fortan songs und mit sehnsucht nach
sie nicht gestorben ist
[Musik]
ja ich denke es ist für mich auch so
inneren frieden ruhe
ich denke mein vater wäre auch sehr
stolz mich das gesehen dass ich wieder
zurück bin
das accessoire was aus mir geworden und
ich denke ich sicher sehr stolz auf mich
und ja also wirklich für dich ich bin so
so schlagzahl und ich finde jetzt ist
natürlich verzeichnen sonst wäre ich
auch nicht
es tut mir einfach sehr wird das ist so
ein trauriges leider kite und
[Musik]
füreinander und jonagored dreist
deutschlandtermine hätte sie in die
vergangenheit nie entdeckt und sich mit
seiner geschichte versöhnt in der
schweiz fort unterdessen ganz andere
geschichte klar zeit zollikofen im
kanton bahn da wohnt sie mag sie plant
ein raise wo ihr das labor für immer
wird für andere zimmer wird zum ersten
mal ist heimatland vor ihrem vater flüge
in bonn
[Musik]
vor nicht allzu langer zeit hatte
webseite machen sich extrem gedanken was
passiert wenn ein kaputter denn der
kontakt zu den verwandten und seppli
wahnsinnig beschäftigt und es
beschäftigt mich die wort gemeldet ist
an dieser 80er jahren wird deutschland
die schweiz seine vier geschwister die
und david immer nur an sich sie größte
wunsch das zimmer da teil von der
familie endlich generiert ich finde
großartig es ist eine große freude für
mich dass das irgendwie immer jetzt
diese möglichkeit bekommt nach ihnen zu
gehen ein land das man muss sehen leute
kennenlernen und meine familie da die
die warten darauf warten darauf dass das
die kinder einmal nach jeder kommen
vater und doch trennen die immer so eine
gute beziehung wie hüte als teenager
zimmer objekte majid rebelliert sie
jetzt kürzer oder saniert erlaubt
nämlich meist das ist besser für dich
und ob denn überhaupt nicht im bahnhof
gestanden hat auf mich wartet und mit
songs ziemlich klar die reise wird sie
mit ihrem renault machen
die zwei sind ein jahr zusammen und ein
zwei hinterhalte am anfang mit
speziellen situationen sie
[Musik]
tatsächlich so wie wir sie kennen und
offen
aber der gedanke dass monica oder nehmen
wir das sehr offene leute eigentlich
familie dann kriegst ganz so gut ist
auch wenn der große schritt
und das braucht natürlich wehmut und
besitzt bin ich immer als mit 16 brief
geben ihre anreise aber immer zwei
schwangerschaften oder
[Musik]
jetzt also endlich klappte mit 30 das
land wo so komplett anders ist als tweet
dass immer die mutter celsius paar mal
in der heimat von marx sie und weiß was
man muss es einfach wirklich ganz ganz
locker
das macht unterm jusi platzgewinn frau
im iran ist ob durch trage so gut sind
wir ärger verursachen sehr speziell und
[Gelächter]
meeting ja was machst du es gut einer
woche
[Musik]
simon quent die verwandte vor ihrem
vater nur vom telefonieren mit ihrer
cousine nervt sie der angst und dockt
[Musik]
mein sohn hat mich gefunden
bye bye bye bye
[Musik]
rookie die usa
der stadt rikuzen vergangenheit
verarbeiten
[Musik]
pizza bietet der sofort die ganze
familie zum znacht insel strandet lotte
donald er nach tucson nur zwei weitere
töchter überholt melissa und tammy
sus nicht die eltern nur eine chance
hingesehen die jünger
ja so ist vertagt
[Musik]
und es kommen überraschungsgast am don
susan er mit ihm ab und zu kontakt
gesehen hätten sie sich mehr als 20
jahren immer
[Musik]
ok
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und wenn ein hund
das familientreffen wird nur größer die
unerwartete ritalin 3
trotzdem so viel gemeinsam hand und muss
ich zerstöre
[Musik]
ein spezieller moment
meine freunde von polizist
kaum
[Musik]
sie selbst wuchs sie in acht ist so
wenn man das zu fliegen war schon mal
grantig
[Musik]
der schöne blick
[Gelächter]
es geht nur viele nachteile für die drei
der big ist ein erster schritt
bevor es mit simon ihre reizvolle
ostbahnhof die iranische botschaft ihre
forderte majid begleitet sie
[Musik]
viele situationen befreien sich für mich
und das ist nicht mal so eine situation
in der die bhs sprachbarrieren gibt mit
dem formular ausgefüllt
iran ist und das verstanden haben und je
nach fragten ihn natürlich sehr froh in
amnestie plötzlich hauptrolle in wer sie
nun ihr täglich braucht sie ein
iranisches gas zu mir reisen dauern
vision finance morita jap ignoriert
haben morgenstern morgen die fehlende
sprachkenntnisse sind aber zum glück
kreise hinter nicht
[Musik]
bis jetzt läuft alles nach plan und der
lang ersehnte reichsstadt mit dem weg
kommt mir meine trug in rochester vor
der abreise zu sehendes bild gemalt das
wozu ihre liebste geschenk
darum sind susan heizpilz verschnitte
damit jeder erteilt voraus erinnere
kaputter ihr vater ihre mutter und die
schwester dannii militärs verstoß wähle
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
susan flugzeug wieder zurück vorher wird
sie nur möglichst viel zeit mit ihrem
bad verbringen
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu dessen rettet das ist
das postcarré places susan und ihre tat
sind sehr unterschiedlich das hat sie
deine tag prozesstag merkt so
zurückhaltend die schweiz susan nicht ob
sie ihm auch so wichtig ist wie er ihre
obwohl sie jetzt andere behnisch
vermisst
das ist toll geworden
nur zwei tage doch nicht sieht sind die
tochter zeigen dass sie geeignet die
beiden händen ausflug plant wo sie nur
zu zweit genießen
[Musik]
in zollikofen vorfreude auf das
verschwundene vor das portal hat salons
in iran aber behörde hat die bewilligung
für skoda team nicht rechtzeitig
ausgestellt
zimmer und der emo sind enttäuscht
eine stunde
[Musik]
am telefon ist natürlich war sehr gut
das geklappt vor augen ist natürlich
politischen drucks der später die ganze
familie
wo immer wieder kart wii ist habe ich
freute mich meine motivation für sie
natürlich extrem es
die koffer waren gepackt sie die langen
jagd und natürlich die ganzen kopf
täglich millionen von nachfahren haben
wir zu wenig
ja das war die ganze ausbeute noch einen
koffer zur tuba bass werberat foto mit
fox channel oskar sima ihre
verwandtschaft im iran informiert
gestern hab mit meinem bruder und das
heißt die familie da die allem was ich
gesagt hatte die wahlen schon die hatten
hoffnung gehabt eventuell klappt war sie
aber als ich gestern gesagt hat nicht
geklappt
dann habe ich gemerkt die sicht vom eine
flut der hat tränen magen gehabt
das mini vorbereitet patrick jung doch
nicht unglaublich es war also wirklich
nicht mehr im werk stunde
galuska hoffnung an ihn verloren das
möglich
ob das mal
richtig tief aus
in die show
optimale die fremde heimat doch noch
keine lehre zeigt sich bald
die usa wollen mit ihrem ford wichtige
frage klar
ja wirklich unsicher ob sie will
und nur reis forderung der jetzige mit
seiner frau zurück zu seinen wurzeln im
moment vor dem sturm wenn sehr viel
verwandschaften und ferien in china und
da ich lass mich überraschen was es
ankommt
nächste woche bei mir nie fremd heimat